[Music]
you always bring the energy you always
bring the pranks you got a lot of
tension with living here in LA how is
your living situation now did you learn
anything from from those viral moments
um yeah no I definitely learned that
like the the way I act and the things I
say can be taken in the wrong way a lot
of the times when I'm just being like
goofy and messing around which sucks but
you know that's the way the media is and
like I said I was apologize to our
neighbors and we're trying to make the
living situation better for everyone how
are you in the neighbors we're good I
wish I had a meeting with them and we're
working on moving out it's the only way
to fix the problem because the Jake
callers are just always outside Deb I'll
dab again you don't I'm saying they're
never leave your house yeah savages so
what is the solution Rena
I don't know somewhere far away we got
to get out and what about things with
you and Disney how are they now
good I mean Disney was like such an
amazing experience always for me such a
huge part of my life I literally have
like the Mickey Mouse tattooed on me was
a dream come true and I'm always rooting
for the bizarre broadcast always rooting
for Disney Channel and I see us working
together in the future so I love them
and they'll always be a part of my life
well you got plenty going on what are
you most excited about next the thing
I'm most excited about is to continued
just to grow my vlog channel and
continuing to innovate content there as
well as making more music and might be
working on some movies and TV shows